[Música]
cuando nació mi hijo chucho
con una situación mucho muy diferente
muy difícil porque él nació muerto la
doctora me pregunta señora lo animamos
si yo digo así pues no sabes no te están
hablando se están diciendo si yo dije sí
ya muy enojada y ya me dices
pues un niño va a tener un problema en
el cerebro ya usted va a ser la culpable
de cómo venga su niño y yo dije bueno
puede que te están hablando que te están
diciendo yo no sabía nada inmediatamente
chucho ingreso a un hospital de tercer
nivel
ahí me lo recibió el doctor rubén
él era el director de neurología ahí
estuvo chucho lo estuvieron atendiendo
paso el tiempo
nadie me dijo que iba a tener una
discapacidad todos los doctores decían
bueno si va a tener una discapacidad
pero que está adecuado a los tres años
chucho se puso muy mal lo internamos le
hicieron una operación delicada le
pusieron una sonda gástrica por donde él
ahorita hasta ahora se alimenta el
doctor salió y me dijo señora su hijo
salió bien pero la ciencia ya hizo todo
lo que tenía que hacer por su hijo
a partir de ahora lo que su hijo le dure
y es responsabilidad de usted y yo
todavía dije bueno busque ganancia como
como lo hago como lo voy a tratar nadie
se acerca a decirte cómo vas a tratar a
tu hijo ni cómo le vas a hacer
en ese momento pues con el perdón de
ustedes yo dije pos doctor
porque yo no sabía cómo atender yo a mi
hijo nadie se acerca a guiarte a decirte
explicarte vamos a hacer esto por esto
por aquello nadie dice nada entonces en
ese momento pues yo me sentí muy mal
estaba yo frustrada estaba yo enojada
estaba enojada con la vida estaba
enojada con dios le preguntaba porque a
mí porque a mi hijo
o sea todo fue un caos un total caos en
mi vida este teniendo a mi hijo
internado no sabía yo que hacer
me la vivía yo en el hospital
salió 88 nos fuimos a casa volvió a
ponerse mal a los 7 años el doctor que
me lo había tenido al principio el
doctor rubén
me vio y me dijo en mi desesperación yo
creo que me vio muy mal y me dijo vos
señora que ya acepta lo sea ya acepte
que su hijo no va a caminar que su hijo
no va a hablar que su hijo no se va a
mover
y yo me quedé frustrado
yo dije yo la que voy a hacer
fue un momento muy difícil un momento
muy duro para mí me salí como toda
cobarde me salí del hospital me voy a
sentar a una banca
y ahí cerca del hospital una banqueta
perdón y entonces me puse a llorar
lloré no sé cuánto tiempo no sé si
fueron horas momentos pero estuve lloré
lloré
y al último me desahogué me paré alguna
vez una terapeuta nos dijo o sea ustedes
tienen cinco minutos para enojarse
gritan dramas y quieren trabajar 25
minutos se me paran y a lo que sigue fue
lo que hice me paré me metí al hospital
entré a ver a mi hijo y lo vi y le dije
mi vida yo ya no voy a pedirle nada a
dios ya me voy a quedar contigo así como
está así no las vamos a echar yo voy a
hacer todo lo posible por que tú estés
bien porque yo esté bien
así nos vamos a ir mi amor no hay de
otra ya no voy a pedir lo que ya no va a
ser no vas a caminar no me vas a hablar
y modo así me quedo si así dios nos
permite que nosotros estemos así nos
vamos a quedar
estos fueron unos momentos muy difíciles
cuando me dan de alta chucho le dice el
doctor rubén
señora ya vaya hacia su casa
tiene familia sí doctor si tengo familia
pues vaya y recupera a su familia haga
todo lo que tenga que hacer por su
familia yo dije bueno va 17 vienen los
pases en el hospital
yo me olvidé de mi familia me interesaba
el niño llegó a la casa y que creen ya
no había familia
mi hijo ya se había publicado toda la
situación toda la discapacidad de chucho
en la sufrió
no aguanto no aguanto se fue por un lado
más fácil este tomo decisiones muy
fáciles para él
desertó en ese momento desertó mi hija
pues ya tenía 17 años ella lo tomo
muchísimo mejor ella lo entendió y pues
hasta ahora llevo una relación con ella
con mi hijo no conmigo ya no hay ninguna
relación como les digo a de cierto
con mi esposo pues
fue la excusa perfecta de haberme yo yo
siete años y la excusa perfecta para no
hacer atrás su responsabilidad así se
quedó
y me quedé yo en mi casa y seguí
adelante
en ese tiempo varias personas y aquí de
la alcaldía débil falta nos juntamos
varios papás con niños con discapacidad
nos reunimos para hacer un centro de
rehabilitación una asociación civil que
es ahora se llama hacienda formada con
padres con hijos con discapacidad por
qué porque acá en la zona de mil falta
es mucho mucho muy difícil encontrar
atención médica para estas personitas
todos nos tenemos que ir hasta el centro
y pues los niños crecen y pasa entonces
muchos papás nos juntamos esa la
formamos desde el 2005 eso fue uno de
los de mis grandes proyectos que yo hice
en eso me enfoqué en eso me
ocupar todo mi tiempo va a todo mi
tiempo ahora yo les puedo decir a paso
del tiempo a paso de los años que si se
puede hacer una vida que si hay una vida
más limitada así si hay una vida más
limitada no es igual la vida pero si se
hace una vida y que cree que yo pensé
que había perdido una familia pero yo no
perdí una familia mi familia se
reestructuró mi familia ahora escucho
mi mamá de 84 años con un evento
cardiovascular esa es mi familia y una
relación maravillosa que tengo con mi
hija si se puede yo les aconsejo yo les
pido que cuando llegue una persona con
discapacidad a su casa busquen ayuda
psicológica
por caminar y él me dijo si nadie me
dijo que yo tenía que buscar una ayuda
que tenías que hacer por acá que tenías
que hacer allá para recobrar una familia
no nadie me dijo a mi familia se perdió
la que yo tenía que yo dejé esa se
perdió pero ahorita pues si se puede
hacer una familia si se puede hacer una
familia diferente así que hay clases de
familias diferentes si se puede si se
puede hacer una vida si se puede vivir
con una persona con discapacidad
es muy importante asumir tu realidad
y con eso te conlleva aquí con todo lo
que tú has trabajado la meta no es ser
feliz es con todo lo que has vivido con
todo lo que has hecho aprendes a ser
feliz eso es lo que a mí me ha
funcionado mucho creo que a todos los
demás les puede funcionar ojala que
ustedes puedan hacer todas estas cosas
por sus hijos o por sus familiares una
base muy importante
el doctor uwe fue muy duro conmigo pero
creo que eso yo lo necesitaba porque
tenía 7 años de pérdida perdiendo me
él me dijo ojalá sra
que valga la pena salvar tantas veces
salchicha
porque niños como chucho sufren
violencia en su casa sufren violaciones
maltratos
los padres como no trabajan
sus emociones
descargan toda su vida y su frustración
con sus hijos entonces él me dijo ojalá
que no me equivoqué con usted señora
ojalá que salvar a chucho haiga valido
la pena tantas veces y tanto como usted
se ha aferrado ojalá que yo nunca tenga
que tener en urgencias a chucho tratando
de reanimar por un abuso sexual por una
golpiza por una quemada de cigarros eso
es lo que a mí me hizo salir y dije no
solo le va a pasar a mi hijo porque por
eso mi hijo me tiene a mí no me importa
haber perdido todo lo que perdió en el
camino porque he ganado a un hijo
especial un hijo que me ha dado la
fuerza para seguir adelante
mis nietos ahora me pregunta
agua limpia que hubieras hecho si chucho
no hubiera nacido y yo les digo ay mis
amores sea chuches el ancla de mi vida
por chucho tuve que aprender
rehabilitación por chucho hecho si anda
porque yo he luchado muchísimo si no me
jala la rienda dijo o sea me desbocó
regrese boca lo amo sé que hay un amor
tan grande hacia mi hijo que eso es lo
que me ha permitido me ha permitido
estar aquí me ha permitido poder
preparar en frente el valor que yo
necesitaba yo lo tengo ahorita con
chucho es una cosa maravillosa yo por
eso les digo busquen ayuda psicológica
por favor
porque a mí me tomo siete años y pensar
que yo había perdido una familia no nada
más se quitó del camino la gente que no
debe de estar yo siempre he comentado
que yo he hecho tenemos una fiesta bien
grandota
tienen invitados se van invitados llegan
otros pero el núcleo sigue ahí y no con
esto quiero decir que ya se terminó esto
sigue y sigue hasta que dios hasta que
dios lo quiera
hasta que dios me lo permita por eso les
digo yo una mujer que no tuvo estudios
una mujer que ha luchado mucho que ha
llegado a ser mamá hasta de su mamá si
se puede si yo pudo si yo he podido
porque ustedes no van a poder claro que
van a poder yo le doy gracias a dios por
haberme dejado ser la mamá de chucho y
le doy gracias a chucho por haberme
permitido ser su mamá
[Aplausos]
[Música]